actor Craig T Nelson has had a long
career in Hollywood both in film and TV
but the role he's probably best
remembered for his football coach Hayden
T Fox on the 90s ABC sitcom coach he won
an Emmy for his work on the hit series
and went on to star on to other
long-running shows the CBS cop drama the
district in NBC's family tearjerker
Parenthood he still pops up in movies
here and there but for the most part
Nelson isn't as much of a screen fixture
as he once was here's what he's been up
to let him go Nelson landed the part of
patriarch Zeek Braverman on parenthood
right after he turned down a similar
role on a more popular show ABC's Modern
Family Nelson was offered the chance to
play family patriarch Jay Pritchett a
role that went to Ed O'Neill in an
interview with Access Hollywood live
Nelson said he liked the script and like
the people on Modern Family but the
producers didn't offer him the amount of
money he felt he deserved after six
seasons parenthood left the air in 2015
with spoiler alert a pretty devastating
finale
Zeke dies after a long battle of heart
problems Nelson wasn't happy about the
way his character or the show went out
telling The Hollywood Reporter I think
the series should have gone on I still
don't know why it was pulled he added
that he never got on board with his
character dying although he thought the
death was really dignified nice and
emotional failed revival in 2015 after
Parenthood came to an end NBC attempted
to bring back ABC's coach the network
was so confident that the coach revival
would work in fact it skipped the pilot
phase and ordered the show straight to
series set to star Nelson and several
other original cast members maybe a risk
you know it's going to be fine
that's what's so exciting about trying
to make it work the plot focused on
Hayden Fox has adopted son Tim launching
a football program at a prestigious
college and enlisting his recently
widowed father to help but in August
2015 NBC cancelled the project after
only one episode was filmed in front of
a studio audience which was never
released and has yet to be leaked
promising pilot it looked like Nelson
had a big TV comeback in the works in
2017 when he was cast in the pilot for
raised by wolves the comedy had an
impressive pedigree oscar-winning
screenwriter Diablo Cody wrote the pilot
based on a British series co-created by
popular English humorist Caitlin Moran
about a single mother raising five kids
this is us producer Greg Berlanti came
on as an executive producer and the cast
included Georgia king of HBO's Vice
Principals ABC passed on the show and
producers tried to shop it around to
cable networks but there haven't been
any takers yet charity work while Nelson
wants famously Wade not paying income
taxes to protest the welfare state I've
been on food stamps and Welfare anybody
help me up
no he's given plenty of his time to
organizations that help others get back
on their feet
Nelson has worked with a drug and
alcohol rehabilitation charity called
the drug education council and spoke at
the organization's annual luncheon in
2017 in 2009 he mentioned on hannity
that he supports dogs for vets a group
that pairs shelter dogs with returning
military personnel as well as a group
that grants scholarships to veterans
children extracurriculars the guy who
played a coach and all the right moves
in coach doesn't stand on the sidelines
in real life
instead he's an active golfer in 2013 he
told the golf content network that he
has a handicap of eight which as golfers
no means Nelson is pretty good although
he says quote the ability to maintain
that number seems to come and go his
strengths are chipping and putting which
he says he'll practice for up to two
hours a day he's also a regular at
celebrity-studded pro-am tournaments
Nelson also loves motorsports in fact in
1991 he went to auto racing school and
soon after entered the Toyota Celebrity
Long Beach Grand Prix finishing in third
place at that point Nelson said he was
hooked he started driving in the World
Sports Car Series also known as the
International Motor Sports Association
and told Motor Trend that it was tough
to break into the sport and be taken
seriously but Nelson proved he had the
right
stuff and was voted the racing
organization's most improved driver
which he quipped was better than winning
the Emmy a look ahead nelson has worked
steadily since coach ended in 1997 and
it looks like he'll be busy in 2018
Nelson will join an all-star cast in the
comedy book club about a group of women
in their 60s whose lives get a jolt of
excitement when their book club reads
and really gets into Fifty Shades of
Grey
Nelson's most famous gig and the one
that made the most money at the box
office involved only his voice he was
Bob Parr aka mr. incredible and Disney
Pixar's 2004 superhero movie The
Incredibles and a sequel is in the works
set to be released in June 2018 plot
details are scant but director Brad Bird
said that Bob has shifted gears to
become a stay-at-home dad
living in a new house that's a cross
between a dream house and a super lair
brad has done such a good job on the
story and John Walker and it it's like
it's a lot of fun and yeah I think it's
gonna be great thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]